here's my quick little review of the
remake of Freaky Friday and ironically I
might actually have more to say about
this one because I think this is one the
few remake that's better than the
original the set up is still the same
it's still a girl and her mother who
switch places but this time it's played
by Jamie Lee Curtis and Lindsay Lohan
and truth be told I just think their
performances are better and on top of
that I think they take more of the
opportunities that's offered to them
with this scenario not only do they make
fun of their celebrity like when Jamie
Lee Curtis looks at herself and says she
looks like the Crypt Keeper but there's
also more opportunity in the fact that
well the mothers allowed to work in this
version and to me that's part of what
can make it really funny a child going
into the work world and not knowing what
to do in the original the mother stayed
home and I'm not gonna act like that's
always easy peasy either but there's
just more comedic possibilities with
going into the office and on top of that
our youth at that time got a little bit
more cutting-edge with technology and
bands and trying to be more hardcore and
all that fun stuff and well that's more
fun to see an adult try to fit into even
though if yes of it is getting a little
dated but to me it's still funnier Elle
I think the original Freaky Friday
actually might have been a little
funnier it feels a little bit more dated
like what she did get a little bit more
into the hippie culture protesting or
the wars or something I don't know just
something to make it a little funnier
but in this one they take every
advantage and it's a ton of fun
once again Lindsay Lohan is great both
as the teen and as the adult in the
teens body and Jamie Lee Curtis does a
wonderful job as only she's great as the
Stern mother but also great as the kid
in the adult body that's trying to have
fun but learning responsibilities and I
don't know maybe because more of these
cliches have been done in the past there
is more of this pressure to not repeat
them and yeah you got hit a few and they
do but at the same time they tried to
keep it a little bit more fresh which I
like they try to throw in new weird
things with the current generation which
i think is a big difference between
something like The Parent Trap remake
and the original where really there
wasn't that much of an update here
there's a huge update technology has
changed and schools have changed and
the idea is an adult trying to go into a
kid's body and trying to adapt it's much
funnier because you know how much adults
are behind on all that stuff
particularly parents so I'm not
necessarily blaming the original movie
for not being good enough it's just that
I think with the changing times with the
upgrade and technology and more women
going into the work world and stuff
there's just more comedy to it and like
I said before getting rid of a lot of
past cliches but still keeping the ones
that are probably needed to make the
story work and I know there's a lot of
people are gonna love the original and
that's fine go ahead and like it there's
nothing really wrong with it it's just
in my opinion there's a lot more that's
done in this one they're definitely fun
movies to compare and contrast so when
you get a chance maybe watch them
back-to-back and decide which one you
like best for me though it's definitely
the remake